I don't necessarily think the queen was
a style icon because she didn't dress to
be emulated and copied but she had this
Timeless sense of style so she was
always I suppose in fashion given the
fact that she was always carrying out
engagements and you know a very busy
working woman as Queen and you know the
Wardrobe was really important so she
didn't ever want hemlines to be too
short and she didn't want things to be
showing too much flesh she needed
certain Fabrics that wouldn't crease
when she was getting in and out of the
car and she loved color so she would
never wear black unless she was in
mourning for the queen it was all about
being seen and often not heard but the
colors of her outfits and what she wore
was really important the queen hated
anything that was flimsy so she liked
weighty clothes you know clothes that
hung beautifully clothes that were
beautifully tailored she loved walls and
you know heavier fabrics and there was a
really practical reason to not wanting
to wear floaty dresses and remember in
her youth she had the most beautiful
figure she was absolutely gorgeous but
she hated the idea of perhaps coming
down a plane or stepping out into a gust
of wind and her skirts lifting up so she
very cleverly used to have her dresser
stitch in weights into the hems of her
skirt lines to keep those skirts hanging
down in the right way and to stop them
from lifting up so I think it was always
common sense and practicality above
style but she was just effortlessly
stylish I think quite a lot of the
Royals have learned their lessons
actually I always remember being with
the Duchess of Cambridge as she then was
Kate we'd arrived in Calgary in Canada
for an engagement and as she was on the
tarmac the wind came up and The Duchess
he was wearing this beautiful yellow
dress didn't know what to do with
herself because she was greeting a
little girl and as she did her dress
just flew up I think those photos have
not quite seen the light of day but it
just goes to show that when it comes to
Royal dressing the queen really got it
right with practicality over and above
style you know she loved her tartans she
loved her Classics she didn't really
depart too much from what she knew
worked for her so if you look back at
her wardrobe the dress coat is a staple
of the royal wardrobe Day dresses you
rarely saw her in trousers apart from
when she was riding her horse Elizabeth
never set out to be a style icon but
because she came to the throne So Young
when she was in her mid-20s 25. she was
absolutely exquisitely beautiful as a
young Queen I think we forget now but
she was So Glamorous she would turn up
at State dinners and receptions wearing
fur stalls and dripping with diamonds
and just looking absolutely Exquisite
you know if you were lucky enough to be
with her on the Dance Floor she would
often wear an off-the-shoulder dress and
her fur stalls and look really like a
movie star since she would play with
color she loved color and she'd
experiment with patterns as well and I
and I certainly think in her later years
she was never afraid to wear strong
colors I always remember her at her 90th
birthday celebration since she came out
from the Buckingham Palace balcony
wearing neon green and we all christened
her on neon Queen but it was remarkable
she could pull off neon at 90. I think
because the queen was a woman of very
few words let's not forget she never
actually gave an interview we never
really knew what she felt about certain
things she used her wardrobe as a way of
expressing herself the queen often used
her wardrobe to convey messages where
often she wasn't able to say anything
when she arrived in Canada more than
giving her sort of an opening speech as
soon as she stepped off the plane there
wearing red and white or the maple
brooch that the people of Canada had
gifted her more often than not she would
speak but that outfit said it all it was
her way of paying tribute to the country
that she was visiting and then when she
visited Ireland she wore green which was
the color of Ireland and that was just
an immediate symbol of peace love and
respect for Ireland and I think from
that moment on the tour just went
perfectly the queen of course has an
extensive jewelry collection and a lot
of that is jewelry that has been gifted
to her so the people of New Zealand have
given her a diamond Fern roach which she
would always wear when she went to New
Zealand the people of Canada gave her
the maple leaf also in diamonds and
what's so lovely has been to see the
queen loan that jewelry to other
Generations so we saw Kate wearing the
maple brooch and the judge inches of
Cornwall wearing pieces of jewelry that
the queen also wore to those Nations so
they have sentimental value the queen
used jewelry to send out a message a
message of love and affection for the
nation that she was visiting and in a
lovely sort of gesture handed it down
the generation so that the Duchess of
Cornwall The Duchess of Cambridge could
do the same thing the queen actually I
think was most at home when she was at
Balmoral or she was at Windsor and she
was riding out and so you know you would
see the queen in in jodhpurs and a
riding jacket but she did love a Tweed
skirt and even when she was up walking
in the highlands in Balmoral it would be
boots always muddy and always flat
teamed with a Tweed skirt and she you
know she believed in wrapping up for the
weather whether it was rain or shine
she'd always have her rain Mark and her
dog leads ready by the door to go out
but she did love being casual I think
that's where she felt most relaxed I
think one of the most iconic things
about the queen was her handbag she
always carried a Lorna handbag bag and
they carry the moral warrant it was it
will I think it will forever be the bag
that is synonymous with the queen she
kept very little in it packet of mints a
crisply folded five pound note a compact
mirror and her lipstick but she was
never without that bag and that bag
served another really useful purpose
other than finishing off her outfit
beautifully she would use that bag to
communicate messages if the bag moved
from one hand to another it meant the
queen wanted to be moved on whoever she
was speaking to was deeply dull if she
put the bag on the floor it meant she
wanted to get out of that situation
immediately so the bag was really
fundamental in her conveying messages to
her staff
[Music]